the saw series started out as a fever
dream project for film students james
juan and lee wannel but has since
developed into a whole franchise of gore
the central villain jigsaw initially
presented himself as a non-serial killer
who just wanted to force troubled people
into appreciating and fighting for their
lives
but as the series went on his games
eventually made it clear that he and his
minions just wanted to see people suffer
as a result some installments definitely
turned out better than others
from worst to best here's a ranking of
all the saw movies so far
by the time the seventh piece of the
jigsaw puzzle came into play the series
looked almost nothing like the original
in the pic detective hoffman was so busy
running around cleaning up his own
messes that the day's game seemed like
an afterthought meant only to follow
formula
in fact there were two major group traps
that were completely devoid of value to
the overarching plot
whoever thought it was necessary to have
a man rip all the skin of his back off
in 3d might just be sicker than jigsaw
there were a couple of elements of
redemption like dr gordon making a long
overdue comeback to the series to tie up
a few loose limbs
and there was a kernel of something
interesting in play with a fake jigsaw
survivor at the center but the movie was
frustratingly disjointed and hoffman's
terminator style raid on the police
department laid waste to the entire
framework of jigsaw's legacy
the eighth installment slash revival of
the saw franchise had to start fresh
after the final chapter said game over
to most of the series overarching plot
points
instead of bringing back dr gordon or
another known name to carry out his
bidding the movie introduced a new
survivor turned killer to the fold
by jumping back 10 years to play out one
of jigsaw's old and largely unknown
group traps we're introduced to logan
nelson a mortician who's sneakily
investigating the cadavers of his own
victims while copycatting john cramer's
work to deliver justice to several
dangerous criminals and the police
officer who helped set them free
of course none of this is apparent
throughout the whole movie as tricky
editing and clever cutaways guard the
secret of logan's true identity until
the very end
after he finally ensnares his mark
everything that's happening to jigsaw's
victim seems to be in real time
making the third act a whirlwind of
explanations and montage moments
it's a suitable sequel and certainly
carries forward the atmosphere and
carnage saw fans have come to know
but it also barely offers anything new
and leaves some very loose threads
dangling
the third installment of the saw series
was one of the most problematic for
several reasons
for starters the victims were completely
sympathetic and even less deserving of
their fates than anyone else
submitting the father and mother of a
drunk driving victim to torture trials
just because they're not grieving the
way you might want them to
that's cruel even for jigsaw even worse
was the fact that the new traps for this
installment were unnecessarily gruesome
to the point of being unwatchable at
times
and let's not forget about the table saw
brain surgery we just had to watch
unfold
sure it was a clever turn of fortune
that the person who was really being
tested was protege number one amanda
but the choice of victims here seems to
exhaust the whole generous grim reaper
identity
jigsaw crafted for himself in the
previous picks making sol 3 among the
series slackest chapters
whereas saw 5 managed to make detective
hoffman interesting
saw 6 did not since he had already
killed off strom and the spat of drug
addicts and other officers who'd run
afoul of jigsaw were dead as well
hoffman's victims list became pretty
arbitrary and ridiculous
i do like how brutality feels mark
this time he picked on a pair of
predatory loan sharks and one
particularly nasty insurance adjuster
who denied john kramer coverage for some
experimental cancer treatments
bearing in mind the fact that this movie
was released in the wake of the subprime
mortgage crisis
it's understandable why the filmmakers
might try to get political and punish
greedy people
however the plot was still flimsy and
underexplored and seemed extra gruesome
just for the sake of shock value
combined with some terrible acting and
forced twist it became stock schlock
long before the timer ran out
the redeeming factor in the movie that
keeps it from landing last on this list
is that hoffman's voyeuristic copycat
game in the beginning was a pretty
decent metaphor for the saw series as
old for the fourth installment director
daryn lynn bausman decided to delve into
john kramer's wretched rationale by
bringing his tragic history with his
wife into the picture along with another
secondary psycho to fill in the timeline
gaps as john kramer took his leave of
the world
but the central player of the game's
lieutenant rigg was wholly undeserving
of his trial
so what if he was passionate about his
job and missed out on a family vacation
or two
the punishment never really matched the
crime in the series but especially so
for rig
that said the clever culmination of
events at the end was a fresh surprise
that saved the story
the fact that jigsaw was still in
control of his crew even while lying
cold on the autopsy table was
delightfully bonkers and managed to
renew any fading interest in what was
next
by the time we got to the fifth film it
was detective hoffman who'd taken over
jigsaw's kill crew
he was sloppy enough to attract some
heat from on high in the form of fbi
special agent strom
strom was obsessively committed to the
cause of nailing his prime suspect even
after escaping his own death trap by way
of an inkpen tracheotomy
so the game of cat and mouse that ensued
between them was pretty epic meanwhile
the games that were afoot and saw 5 were
also a bit more precise and interesting
the victims of this round weren't just
helplessly being ripped to shreds but
instead at least pretended to use their
brains before engaging those mechanisms
that would cause their eventual demise
the gore of the games was also
mercifully dialed down a notch which
gave more room for the sound effects
team to fill in the blanks rather than
always leaning on graphic visuals to get
the job done
the film's return to a teamwork element
in the games was refreshing and the
passionate pursuit of strom culminated
in a crushing twist ending that was as
jaw-dropping as anything that came
before it or after
spiral from the book of saul strips the
saw franchise down to its basics no more
jigsaw no more twisted convoluted
continuity it's just traps a serial
killer some pig masks and a mystery
one that in this case may be a little
too easy to solve
jigsaw copycat
that could be difficult as a way of
breathing new life into the franchise
spiral is a huge success
in terms of filmmaking this is the
slickest saw yet and while its style
isn't as aggressively edgy as the first
movies its cast is bursting with star
power
in addition focusing on chris rock's
scrappy detective zeke banks instead of
the killer and their victims offers a
new perspective on the ever brutal saul
universe the traps are much simpler than
the rube goldberg s
devices from the later saw films but
they're still suitably uncomfortable and
somewhat less graphic
the problem spiral isn't all that scary
by emphasizing the police investigation
over everything else spyro plays more
like a police procedural or
crime thriller sure it's tense and the
trap scenes are still full of bloody saw
charm but outside of a few jump scares
you'd be hard-pressed to call spyral a
real horror flick
as a plain old movie spiral is likely
the best and most accessible installment
since the first one
is it really a superior saw experience
though to die hard fans probably not
director daryn lynn bausman managed to
avoid the sophomore slump with the first
sequel to saw in fact the film gamely
expanded the world that had been
established in the original and offered
a new vein of entry for the subsequent
sequels to float on
the backbone of a selected group of
victims stuck in a dirty doom house
where they're racing against the clock
to flesh out their own shared histories
was still there but the movie managed to
layer that element with a compelling
subplot about jigsaw's arresting officer
detective matthews and his missing son
and on top of that there was a surprise
return of amanda which answered the
question of what would actually happen
to those few who managed to survive
jigsaw's games unlike some of the other
sequels the entire plot was pretty
polished and managed to give the series
some staying power so movie 2 is the
second best of the series
there is something very artful about
saw's approach to the macabre that made
the movie such an indelible experience
the puzzle pieces of skin taken from
victims bodies were meant to be symbols
of what was missing from people's lives
but they were also a collective metaphor
for the audience's job of digesting
everything that happened in the film
the small scale setting of two and a
half people locked in a bathroom playing
a game of clue for their lives was
surprisingly effective
and so were the whirly cam montage
tricks used to show off other terror
traps
so saul opened the door to much more
interest in exploring the sick sad world
of jigsaw
especially after it ended on such a
twist that it was decidedly not game
over
the movie was still far from perfect of
course the film had some moments of lazy
acting and low-budget camera angling
that are pretty cringe-worthy upon
review
but even if it didn't boast the slick of
cinematography known to hollywood
so it was still an original and very
disturbing abstraction for the auteurs
to explore and was executed with
impressive efficiency and invention
for those reasons it's still the best
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite movie franchises are
coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one